framber valdez who was so key to the
astros postseason run last year is back
from a finger injury he makes his fifth
start of the year tonight he has been
fantastic so far a lot of the white sox
will get their first looks at valdez
tonight anderson punches it to altuve to
start the night two pitches to get the
white sox lead off man down valdez faces
adam engel the center fielder
nice back door breaking ball the
excellent freezing slider and angle is
down on three pitches two up and two
down now the number three man mankata
hitting right handed get up the middle
it's a slow roller the bouncer taken by
correa comes across and makes a good
throw and that'll retire the side lance
lynn and here's what we're looking for
you got a very fast ball dominant
pitcher against the best fastball
hitting team in baseball three different
fastballs he will not deviate from that
plan adam he will attack these astros
hitters with fastballs and the astros
hitters they hit fastballs so this is
going to be a fun matchup to see which
one wins but i cannot wait to see this
battle el tube he has hit lancelin well
to odell tuvay and he tops one on a
bouncer to third what a play by montana
gloving it but a bad throw will allow
altuve to work towards second base and
throw back behind him mendic applies the
tag but altuve is safe for the bag duvet
nonetheless michael brantley steps in
the designated hitter today
and gets him with that 95 mile an hour
fastball elevated that's a huge at-bat
after the error runner on second no ouch
you would expect someone like michael
brantley to a minimum put the ball play
to the right side and get out two bit a
third with one out jordan alvarez steps
in with runners on the corners julie at
first altuve at third one out in the
first inning that one's inside off the
glove of grandal altuve will score and
the astros take the lead i'm not sure if
that was a cross up he yanked it inside
to jordan alvarez but it looked like it
was a catchable ball by yasmani grand
dog that'll bring up carlos correa
payoff delivery
and lance lynn freezes correa with a
fastball strikes out a pair in the frame
randall with a two out single here in
the second the first sox base runner
andrew vaughn the batter andrew vaughn
first pitch swinging valdez tough play
and he throws it away
brondall on his way to third and a
second goes on
finally dug out down the line
and two in scoring position with two
outs for the white sox on a defensive
miscue
by valdez now leory garcia playing for
the first time in a few games trying to
get out of it with this pitch
and he does gets garcia on three
swinging strikes
to close out the inning and strand a
pair bottom of the second robel garcia
steps in for the astros
there's a good pitch another fastball
from lin for a strikeout that's his
third as he gets garcia down there's
jazz mccormick trying to snap in over
10. they cut mccormick down back-to-back
case for lynn okay so that out means
lance lynn has hit exactly 1500 major
league innings he can strike out
maldonado it'll be 1500 strikeouts
swing and a miss strike three
yep 1500 and a third innings 1500 career
strikeouts
now engel with two down
there's a flare out toward right and a
diving attempt but no catch by mccormick
he trapped it angle has a two out hit so
angle aboard for moncada
that's a healthy swing montana drills
one to deep left field and it's off the
base of the wall
that's gonna score a run
engel is around to give the white sox
their first run of the game monkana ties
it up at one a piece
why did you know that dallas out of
curiosity here's brantley brantley has a
chance with a scoring position again
here's the 1-0 and that's pulled to the
right side it could squeak through and
it does they're going to send
altuve around third and he's going to
score
rbi single for brantley it's to one
bradley's 25th ribby correa here who's
in a high leverage count against lynn
with two on and two out in the third of
a 2-1 game
and he misses low ball four and the
bases are loaded first walk issued by
lance lynn all right big moment right
here maybe the biggest moment of the
season so far for robel garcia runners
go here's the pitch and it's driven to
right field hooking away from the right
fielder garcia and he'll have to play it
off the wall it's over his head it might
clear him it does a three-run double for
robel garcia and the astros lead five to
one nice and bad by garcia it's a
fastball lanceland's trying to go in he
misses it just enough out over the plate
it gets in on garcia but he gets his
hands in and hits the base of the wall
when he first did i thought laurie
garcia in right field had a chance but
it got over his head you see the
frustration from lancelin nice at bat by
garcia to make him make lancelin pay for
walking carlos correa and another two
out two strike hit martine maldonado
first astro to bat here in the bottom of
the fourth
there's strikeout
1501 as he gets his sixth of the night
we talked about his fastball here's the
slider flash cutter sometimes it's hard
to tell the difference but 85 you see
how out in front mount venato is while
straddling
reaches out and pokes that one to
anderson who has to hurry against one of
the faster players on this astros roster
and one of the faster ones in major
league baseball infield single for miles
straw two outs now for brantley straw
over to second
brantley goes the other way but vaughn
is there trying to get back on it it's
going to go over his head and brantley
will drive in another it's 6-1 houston
somehow someway as the years go by this
guy keeps finding holes in the defenses
that he sees he has retired the first
two batters of every inning angle one
for two here's the pitch from from that
one hit hard and it's stamp
dropped it comes up throwing and rebel
garcia with an outstanding play the line
drive to his left got a glove on it
knocked it down came up spun and threw
him out from the dominican to italy to
the united states to a scout finding him
for the cubs
to having a big night tonight who loves
it your pitcher framber the hive is
strong
listen to miles straw talking to jordan
alvarez about it are you making that
play
third base
you are you making that play
easy
[Laughter]
he said he's making the play easy at
third base astros lead 6-1 over the
chicago white sox top of the seventh
inning from her valdez the lefty back
out there for the astros vaughn a first
pitch infield single in the second
walked in the fourth but left stranded
both times
golf's one deep the other way mccormick
twisting at the wall and it's gone
andrew vaughan with his sixth career
home run and he continues to do it
against left-handed pitching his fifth
against the lefty a much-needed white
sox home run to get on the board for the
first time
since the third he's had a great night
at the plate six and two-thirds of
strong baseball thus far the blemish
here with vaughn's home run a man at
second and two out
engel kind of a half swing mendic takes
off
fires fires into left field and that's
going to get the white sox within three
so that aggressive base running for
mendic does pay off brian stanek
the high strikeout total was rock solid
in the eighth yesterday against moncada
abreu grandahl and lamb struck out a
pair now the tying run comes to the
plate javon solo home run to right in
his last at bat the 1-0 pitch vaughn
pops this one up
a mile in the air correa says i've got
it right behind the mound and he'll make
the catch and that'll retire the side
the white sox threaten but leave two go
to the bottom of the eighth inning as
the astros take a 6-3 lead to their half
of the eighth and carlos correa will
lead it off
the pitch correa hits this one deep to
right field going back looking up forget
about it carlos correa an opposite field
home run in the astros
lead it 7-3
how many times have we seen it carlos
correa
able to extend those arms and ride it
out to right field another minute bait
park home run 13 jacks on the season now
for correa and why does that one run
feel like about five ryan presley has
been rock solid 10 for 11 in save
opportunities he'll go for his first one
of this series astros one out away from
taking the first three of this series
off the fish into right center
mccormick's there
six straight wins
six straight series victories for
houston